ừ ừ
anh alo Chào tất cả bạn
Các bạn thấy màn hình mình chưa ạ
chờ đợi mình thấy nghe nói chọn nhầm mà
nạ OOO
ở lại Ok Ok vợ ạ
ừ ừ
ờ ờ
Tại sao tạo thành bột cuối rồi khi bản
chất là mình bảo lỗi mình sẽ chỉ dạy
lướt qua nhanh hgcs sấy phẳng nó sẽ
không nhanh được như thế này ra quyết
thì mình vẫn phải dạy lại từ đầu các bạn
thế nào muốn lập trình nữa kết hợp với
việc là Switch thì bắt buộc phải làm
xong cái gì đó còn HTML CS thì được ra
các bạn chỉ cần biết cơ bản để làm về cơ
bản thôi
nay học muộn thì rất là muộn hơn cho mọi
hôm như cá thì
8:00 bác đồ vào học mà không ạ
Chừng nào mà muộn hơn rồi đấy thì mình
mình sẵn hàng để nó bạn khiển trách mà
bây giờ chị nó vẫn đúng mà Ừ
anh chạy một phần là mình có nói đây đó
Hôm nay học muộn vì mình soạn bài nữa
gửi bài hôm nay sẽ dài hơn
buổi cuối Sẽ Chẳng Còn nhiều cái hơn kết
hợp với việc là
thực ra là thì mình mình bảo mấy lần
mình ngon sớm để mà tâm sự chia sẻ cái
gì đó
chủ yếu tâm sự hơn chứ chia sẻ thì mình
cảm thấy là đã lẽ phải cuối buổi lắm
chia sẻ thấy ra là bật Bây giờ mình đang
chẳng biết chia sẻ cái gì cả từ đây mình
không không dám mon sớm ăn sớm nói tình
các bạn lại ghét rồi thoát ra gì hết
Ừ
thế thì quan trọng thì cũng đúng Nhưng
mà mình sẽ không dại có bạn gì hết để
làm mọi thứ hai chỉ dạy gì hết để mà làm
cái ra hết về sau mình sẽ nói để các bạn
biết vai đấy là cái gì nghe nói chung ạ
để các bạn hiểu được
ra squat có tác dụng gì thôi Nó được rồi
còn là mình làm cái khóa này thì nó lại
gọi lập trình tức là chúng ta sẽ phải
dùng ngôn ngữ lập trình để mà làm nũng
hoặc là năm có trang web tất cả mình sẽ
chủ yếu cốt có thể bằng VP chắc chắn sẽ
nhiều hơn rất nhiều chiếm Chắc phải bảy
mươi phần trăm
bảy mươi tám mươi phần trăm của cái
trang web p + 10 máy Wave A
ạ
bây giờ chắc à Chuẩn bị trả lời câu hỏi
thôi bây giờ tranh thủ trước thì mình
trả lời cái câu lại câu này trước đi
chứ
không phải là sai chính tả với nhiều bắn
teencode Tôi không biết Không phải bạn
đang bao nhiêu tuổi nữa
ờ Anh ơi em hỏi một câu chắc hơi cũ một
chút
Ừ anh treo cái này thì khó không anh
ở kho với anh không Cái này đa số từ đâu
ạ
Ừ hình như thế à
thế nhưng bây giờ nói thật ra mình không
thể khẳng định được là các ngành công
nghệ thông tin này nó dễ dàng cả
phải bình tĩnh nhìn cái khó chữa trị
những cái này
Ừ thì ah cái này công nghệ thông tin là
không hề họ dễ dàng đến bây giờ bảo dễ
dàng ông không lại bảo tôi lừa mấy ông
nghĩ nhưng mà
cái việc à
Ừ cái việc này nó cảm thấy cho mình khá
Hưng Phú Cần phải làm xong mình sẽ khá
là vui khi mà giải quyết được sau một
cái gì đó chị gần như là tìm được bác
cái hay làm xong một cái tính năng gì đó
hoặc và khiến hôm trước là mình cảm thấy
rất vui khi mà cậu Cái trang web mình
đang chạy mất 3 giây chậm lại mình làm
nó nó chạy thì 0,3 giây ạ Tôi cảm thấy
có nó mình kiểu mình thấy mình hàng
thông minh vãi chưởng với dễ Kiều
Nó là một cái hình thức tự sướng nhiều
hơn ngày ngày tự sướng chứ
khoe với người khác thì người ta có hiểu
gì đâu Đó Ngoại
nói chung là kiểu
A
và cái vui của ngày ngày nữa đó là mình
cảm thấy mình có
nhà mình có tác dụng mình tiểu học có
thể hoàn toàn là làm chia sẻ cho nhiều
người khác khác với nhiều ngành
thực ra mỗi ngày thì đương nhiên là rồi
thường ai giúp đỡ lẫn nhau với Vân ngày
này thì có thể dịch vụ cái gì đó giúp đỡ
ngành kia
Ừ nếu mà mình vẫn phải có tìm được những
niềm vui thôi công việc đấy đúng ạ
Nên là khi khi đấy xong mình chưa rồi
nghĩ việc ở cửa khóa không
mình chỉ nghĩ việc giải quyết và toàn
như nào thôi chúng mình không gặp vấn đề
với việc và thấy khó gì nào ạ
à à
Ừ cái vụ vay Dead ở friend 2 bác em thì
chắc là vì sau mình sẽ nói cụ thể hơn
cho bạn nha Ờ anh biết tổ chức tổ chức
với xanh tại lúc
Ê AK gần đây mình theo dõi cái Tết à
tiếng Việt giàu đẹp thì tôi không khẳng
định được là ông nào sang phải ông nào
không nữa rồi vì có nhiều từ rõ ràng từ
trước là mình tưởng ạ
Nó là như thế người ta không phải thế
bởi vì theo từ Hán Việt Nó là kiểu như
hành ABCD Z thì B không dám bắt lỗi
chính tả người khác này à
ờ ờ
cái tổ chức Anonymous Nếu mà bạn đang
nói chắc là tổ chức liên quan nó như mất
hacker không ạ kìa
Cái này chắc chắn là nhiều biết rồi vào
kiểu thì mình hẹn tưởng nói là thật chia
lúc đầu mình không định theo ngành lập
trình mình theo ngành khách không thì
kiểu gì mình cũng thần tượng với anh này
mà ra đúng không ạ
Ừ nếu mà thực tế đi à mì cay đấy nó vẫn
một phần được thêu dệt cái gì đó là để
cho nó ngầu thôi nhưng mà
số kiểu mình thủy tổ chức này làm ít vụ
không không hẳn nhiều vụ lắm
ở trong giới hacker nhầm thì chắc chắn
nó sẽ có chỗ có nhiều cái nhóm chuyên
làm nhiều vụ hơn
à à
các
tester có cần biết phân em để lấy anh em
mình không
ờ ờ
Ẩm Thực sự thì toàn bộ công việc của
tester thì bị chỉ hiểu cách tương đối
rồi Chắc là cái này các bạn à
cha tra xem giấy tờ Yêu cầu những cái cụ
thể gì thì các bạn học thì ổn hơn
ừ ừ
à Anh ơi Em không biết em thích cái gì
em vẫn cố gắng theo tốt vì nó là ngành
kiếm nhiều tiền Cái này không phải mỗi
chỉ mỗi ngày công nghệ thông tin này mà
đôi khi nó về tắm luôn thua được Ừ
Ừ mình may mắn hơn các bạn ở điểm là
mình tự nhiên mình kiểu có cái góc nhìn
khác đầu tiên mình có góc nhìn khác về
những cái môn học
ở trường
thì các bạn đôi khi có bạn học một cái
môn và các bạn sẽ tự hỏi là môn này có
tác dụng gì trong cuộc sống kiểu thế Tự
nhiên mình học môn Sinh học môn hóa học
môn vật lý Và thậm chí ở các toán nâng
cao Toán kiểu hàm số đại số cái gì nhỉ
thích Phân nó ngọn vân vân vân rồi các
bạn sẽ hỏi là tác dụng gì trong cuộc đời
này mình có ở Dùng cái đấy đi chợ ở đâu
đừng Ngoại nên thành ra là kiểu các bạn
chán học kiểu gì thế
Mình không ngừng như thế mình thấy hợp
tất cả những cái môn đấy Kiểu mình biết
được là lý do đến học những môn đầy kiểu
để rèn tư duy cả để có một tí kiến thức
về em ạ Cái vụ là để vì sao tra Google
Thay vì mình hỏi cái cô cho Google theo
kiểu là cái gì bảy màu ở trên trời thì
mình chỉ được cha là tại sao có cầu vồng
nhãn hãy kiểu thế người có học có người
không đi học mà sẽ khác nhau vài cái chỗ
như thế
A và tương tự thế khiến cho khi mà lên
đại học mình
mình kiểu hoàn toàn thích khá nhiều
ngành chưa Thế thế ngành nào cũng thật
thế à Mình có thể treo được được Kiểu
mình lúc đầu mình nhận định theo cả báo
chí theo cờ
và chia của vì tôi thích tự do ngôn luận
thôi chứ tôi không thích thành liều vào
đâu
thích đi dạy bởi vì mình từng dậy người
khác và cảm thấy à Người ta dễ hiểu lên
thành mình tự tin việc đấy mình còn
thích cả luật bởi vì à
Ừ mình giỏi cãi Chắc thế
Nói chút mà mình thích nhiều ngày
và có nhiều bạn thì không bị thế không
thể bởi vì à Cậu có thể nhàng mà ai
thích là ngành mà kiểu dạng là không
kiếm Như Tiến kết hợp kết hợp việc là
hội bé các bạn bị dễ bị làm hai cả ví dụ
nhé giờ xử mới ông thích hát chẳng ạ
Nhưng mà từ bé đến lớn ông đi học cái
môn âm nhạc ở trường dạy rất hợp làm cho
ông cảm thấy từ Tao không thích dần dần
Không thích nó nữa không đam mê hơn nữa
Trừ khi nhà ông dầu vãi chưởng cho ông
hẳn và các lớp năng khiếu ngay từ hồi bé
không học kiểu trình đại trà ấy thì mình
cái lợi mấy cái môn đấy thì ở trường tôi
còn từng bỏ luôn cả Mun đấy để mà dậy
Cái môn Toán làm bài tập cơ cô cô giáo
chủ nhiệm bỏ môn âm nhạc Mỹ thuật để ba
sinh viên ngồi làm bài tập môn môn chính
là thế làm cho thực sự được Ừ cái đam mê
có bị mất dần theo những hàng đầy so về
sau chẳng biết là ông đam mê Cái gì cả
Sao rồi cùng gì về sau ông theo sự chỉ
dẫn của mấy ông kia bảo là ngành này
đang hót kiếm được việc xong rồi Bố Mẹ
bảo là kiểu
đặt đâu Con ngồi đấy thành ra các bạn
theo cái gì nó rất nửa vời
May mà mình không bị như thế
Ngay từ thì mình bảo ở đây cái gốc rễ
rồi ra ngay từ chiến trường các bạn phải
có tư duy đó kêu
học
được ba đa dạng kiểu thế
khi họ xác định được cái môn mình thích
thì thì về sau theo Đại học
Tại sao cấp 1 cấp 2 cấp 3 học các môn
dàn trải như thế để mà các bạn thực sự
Các bạn thấy thích kể cái môn nào nhất
để mà lên đại học các bạn chỉ chú trọng
những môn đấy thôi đâu như là đi thì học
này mình thấy thực ra nó không Hắn
tự nhiên Thì mình vẫn nhiều chính xác
mình thi vào ngành Công nghệ thông tin
tự nhiên mình phải khi môn văn cần thấy
sai lại chưa
mình bị trượt trường chỉ vì môn Văn Miếu
em
nghe nói thế thì lại hơi đụng chạm ở bên
giáo dục nữa rồi theo đại khá như thế
Mình cảm thấy
đấy cái mình nói về việc là các bạn chọn
ngành rồi Tiếp theo là việc à Ở lời
khuyên cho bạn này
lời khuyên thì
xơ ca nó liên quan Vừa chọn lành đó là
các bạn không nên chọn những kẻ nhàng mà
chỉ nhận ra mình thấy nó Giang Rất là
Hót bởi vì chính vì góc nhìn của bạn như
thế rất nhiều người đang như thế rất
nhiều người rất nhiều trường bây giờ vạn
năm đào tạo công nghệ thông tin thực sự
là vẫn đang đầy người ra có cái bằng
nhôm thất nghiệp mình quen rất rất nhiều
và rất nhiều người bỏ không theo ngày
đấy nên thành ra là
mình không thể khuyên bạn là cứ theo đi
được
Ý bạn nói chung là nếu bạn xem cái lý do
từ hôm trước thì sao bạn vẫn đang thử
theo phải khóa này Thì nghĩa là bạn bạn
cứ theo thử nốt chút tiền cái khóa cơ
bản này bạn thấy phù hợp hay không Không
thì bạn đến chuyện thực sự vẫn còn rất
nhiều ngành khác còn nếu không được thì
chắc là ở bất ông Vỹ phải làm những cái
thứ mình không thích rồi ông
thực là hồi năm nhất của mình mình cũng
làm rất nhiều thứ mà mình từng kể rồi đó
là mình làm
Linh làm từ việc gõ mãi gõ máy này xong
buổi bàn các thứ thứ đủ mọi kiểu để cho
mình cảm thấy mình phù hợp với cái gì
hoặc là chỉ đơn giản là cảm thấy mình
không phù hợp với cái gì để mà về sau
mình khi mình quay lại trường học đấy
thì sẽ phấn đấu Bởi vì thực sự những cái
nhanh chứ không hề phù hợp với mình đâu
thế cho mình chân yếu tay mềm Key ở mình
dân công nghệ cười cùng ngon mà anh ra
là không làm được việc nặng cũng như là
không không kiểu đứng chạy cả ngày được
ra là mình phù hợp với việc ngồi ngồi
trước máy mới gõ chém gió như này còn
được
cái tên bác học điên có nghĩa gì
thực à Có khi cái câu vừa nãy mình đã
trả lời cho cái này rồi đó là trên
trường mình hồi bữa trước sinh trường
mình học có phải rất là giỏi nhé Mình ko
phải con nhà người ta chẳng qua là mình
rất thích kiểu tìm tòi Tìm tìm hiểu các
thứ thứ có khi chạm phải kiến thức ở
trên trường Anh ngồi đây tôi còn kiểu
tôi nhưng mà thằng tôi bảo rồi tôi là
kiểu màu sách mà cái này là tôi nói
chuyện nhằm nhẽo lắm từng Kể câu chuyện
cười bằng cách đọc y nguyên lại câu
chuyện cười ấy và với con trai cười thế
thế nên là
tôi hồi đấy thôi Kiểu cô đơn muốn kết
bạn thêm Tôi ngồi tìm hiểu thêm cả những
cái ví dụ là những cái mà người khác
thích nghe đó về tâm linh này hay ở Về
nhà ạ truyện 18 + vẫn Vân này rồi chuyện
có học vũ trụ thì em ạ xong rồi tìm hiểu
rất nhiều để mã kiểu nói nói ra người
khác thích nghe
thì thế nên là dần dần là kiểu cái mác
bác học điên có họ các mình tìm hiểu rất
nhiều đứa nghèo ngồi đây vẫn chẳng ai
nước gì cả à khi
học xong khóa này là fullback hả thầy
Ừ thì fulltech thì đầu tiên là dịch cho
các bạn chưa biết cái từ này không tách
là kẹo làm được cả fan được bác
anphatland là làm các giao diện này và
bác E là làm cả xử lý nhưng mà phun sách
bây giờ nó đang bị khó thêm một tí thiên
hướng đó là
làm cả bên Forland nghĩa là có cả ra quý
vị ra quyết định xử lý hết ở bên bên
krait bên giao diện khách hàng cũng được
bác em xử lý gì ở một phần thôi nên
phong cách và bao nhiêu nghĩ ám
nhưng đại khái là đúng khóa này chị sẽ
cho các bạn biết qua một tí về giao diện
và chủ yếu là bên papain nhiều hơn nhà
nó cũng sẽ có qua là giao diện rồi ừ ừ
đi tìm cốt mà không biết diễn tả thì cho
dù như thế nào Cái này không phải là mỗi
cốt mà rất nhiều bạn không biết cách kỹ
năng cho Google K thì mình từng nó qua
với kỹ năng cho Gồ rồi
khi con bạn này nói hỏi cụ thể về cốt
thì chắc à các bạn thể inbox hỏi mình
hoặc à hỏi ở trên link discord của nhóm
thì từ khóa cho Google bởi vì đôi khi
các bạn dụng là điển hình nhé các bạn
muốn hiển thị tâm một cái kiểu một cái
cửa sổ bấm vào nói gì để mua cửa sổ hiển
thị lên để bạn điền thông tin em ạ Các
bạn không đi được từ khóa tiếng Anh đấy
là gì Các bạn để hỏi người khác khác trả
lời bạn ví dụ nó làm cái parte 1 cái mua
đồ hiệu Thế thì
khi Cái đấy là kinh nghiệm của người đi
trước thôi chứ được gửi thì không không
có cách nào để mà các bạn biết được toàn
bộ tất cả các từ khóa đấy đâu
và cuối cùng mình trả lời nói có này
mình xin còn
hi hi
Ờ Ờ
mình tin là có nhiều bạn cũng đang dùng
đương nhiên là nhiều bạn với đa số dùng
pin ông ạ Không biết các bạn là crack
crack crack nhiều hơn là mua bản quyền
thì crack chưa cái là nó không tốt sẽ
chặn rồi vì a có thể nó dính thêm tí mã
độc một tí có ông nào nó đang cày cái
kiểu gọi là à Em bé gọi bé cụm từ thường
thế cài một cái kiểu nó có nó sẽ chạy
ngầm trên máy ông và có thể hoàn toàn
khách không Mày không bất cứ lúc nào mà
không nên cài mấy cái kiểu crack thế thì
mày ông đi mua bản quyền à không không
nên kms chứ nhiều nơi ca mới chính là em
bé ờ
và
đương nhiên là
Ừ mình không khuyên các bạn được việc là
dùng hàng lậu cái gì cả nhớ mình mình
thường ai lên cái cái nhóm ở trên
Facebook Hồi trước mình tìm được đó là
nó nó
tên là kiểu kích hoạt Windows hoặc
Office kích hoạt Win dows báo Phí tiên
anh
đấy người ông Tìm mấy cái nhóm này lên
đấy băng họ
mấy anh đấy sẽ kích hoạt cho mấy ông
kích hoạt bằng mình nhớ Active byphone À
cái chỗ kích hoạt thì hôm ấy ông và nó
sẽ Vĩnh Nó gần như vĩnh viễn thì vậy
không biết được cái đấy không biết là
cái đấy nó cơ chế nó như thế nào nhưng ở
chung nhà
chắc là Windows nó cũng cho kiểu lắc lắc
như thế Tôi bảo rồi tôi nói vụ đấy rồi
thở ra Windows hoàn toàn không quan tâm
mấy ông đâu Mấy ông thế mới cho mày
không dễ rách như thế à
anh nói chua miệng để làm nó sẽ uy tín
hơn nữa việc Hôm Cài Hàn Quốc cái phần
mềm từ một cái trang lạ hoặc về đấy Ờ
đương nhiên là mấy ông cũng phải đọc qua
về mấy cái nhóm đấy Đều là mấy cái nhóm
là miễn phí nhưng có nội quy của họ
không phải đọc qua với nội quy trước khi
ông Đăng mày câu hỏi người ta tin nên
không mới ra chặn luôn đấy à
A và kiểu
A và
trong đấy thường người ta sẽ bảo là mấy
ông chia sẻ teamview Thượng Mã teamview
hoặc cả mã
ultraview thì mấy ông đừng có nên bình
luận luôn cái mã ở đấy bởi vì có một cốc
ông Chia sẻ mã đấy Thằng nào nó nhảy đều
vào máy ông này là rất nguy hiểm mấy ông
nên để cho mấy anh kia inbox Và thậm chí
A đầy kỹ xem mày Thế Anh inbox mình là
là người như nào trong mà Nhóm kia hoạt
động như thế nào cho nhóm kia tránh việc
Kiều
đưa mãi cho người lạ mà người ta có thể
chiếm quyền vẫn có thể truyền quyền được
mấy ông
Ừ thế do ông tự cho người khác truy truy
cập vào máy may sóng mạng đi
à à
khi tái Mình vừa trả lời qua tất cả đến
ngày đúng ạ Bây giờ chúng ta sẽ bắt đầu
buổi học thì hôm nay mình sẽ học về Bose
đô và spectre chất cả hai cái này nó đem
là sợi tơ Chính xác là thế thế đều chọn
một cái thẻ nó đó theo ý của mình thì
cái cô Shadow nó sẽ viết theo tội loại
như thế này này Tôi ví dụ trong mấy ông
ừ ừ
à à
em thật sự ở mình cứ Xóa hết toàn bộ cái
bài cũ nhé
à à
ạ Bây giờ sửa mình có thể này
sẽ là đây là link virus cho lại
mình chạy thử nhé ạ
à à
thì
các bạn sẽ thấy là cái này tuy nằm trong
thẻ ra nhưng mà nó chưa Bấm được và nó
chơi hiển thị giống như là mình có thể
bấm được bình thường các bạn thấy nó sẽ
được bôi màu với cậu có thể bấm được khó
chỉ vào biểu tượng này sẽ bấm được đóng
ạ bởi vì à Mình đang thiếu cái Hz cái
đường dẫn để hiểu là nó thể A có thể bấm
được cái mình sẽ cho Hz và nó là sự nó
sẽ nhảy trang trang Google hay gì đó
không ạ
1.com trả nào
Ở
đây các bạn sẽ thấy là bây giờ màu của
nó sẽ đổi sang màu tím tại sao nó lại
sang màu tím
thì
tại sao tự nhiên mình để cảm với vũ màu
đây bởi vì ạ bây giờ xưởng mình sẽ tra
mà sang một cái trang nào đó thế này
thời trang sẽ trả chưa Rồi vào khi nó là
đổi sang màu xanh để ngon nếu việc màu
tím màu xanh ở đây để thể hiện điều gì
màu tím thì có sẽ hình dung được là nó
từng được bấm rồi còn màu xanh để hiểu
nó chưa từng bấm ờ
A và chỉ ở đây thì các bạn thấy biểu
tượng con trò này đúng không ạ và các
thứ từ đây đó ngoan nhé các bạn thấy mặc
định khi một thẻ ra trình duyệt nó sẽ
hiểu và tự tự thêm sẽ cho nó là đổi màu
này gạch chân ở dưới này sôi trỏ chuột
vào thì thì hiển thị ra là có thể bấm
được dấu ngoặc Và nếu mà cái việc
cái việc bấm cái nick một lần rồi thì
màu nó sẽ khác đúng không ạ nhưng mà đây
là mặc định của trình duyệt với mỗi
trình duyệt thường thường là sẽ phát
khác 1 tí nhưng mà giờ sự các bạn không
muốn như kiểu màu như thế các bạn muốn
màu đỏ chói à mã sau khi chỉ vào sẽ có
thêm cái gì gì đó thì sao đúng không Thì
cái này nó là liên quan đến sẽ à Odo tất
cả cách viết kiểu nó vẫn là thẻ ra nhưng
mà vì nó có những cái gọi là trạng thái
khác nhau đều mặc áo kiểu cưỡi Tôi không
biết dùng từ như thế nào Vì tớ bảo rồi
có nhiều từ 0 đến dịch sẽ là kiểu như
này Nghệ A Khi mẫu ngón trỏ chuột vào và
sự tố đổi nó sang màu khác đi đầu nhọn
con kia nó sẽ là hoa vợ nhé
Nó sẽ hai chấm chấm gì vậy không nhiều
lắm thử thực có lâu sẽ là sang màu đỏ
cho này
á thay thế mua chấm Không ạ đó béo khỏe
không hả trọ chuột ở sẽ sang màu đỏ nha
kích thích kích thích cho người dùng
được
Ừ tôi chỉ chuột vào nó sẽ thay đổi gì đó
làm tôi cảm thấy cái thích bấm vào cho
dù đây là link virus trở lại kêu hết cái
Thậm chí có thể hoàn toàn không phải mỗi
đổi màu ông già sử ông cho nền thay đổi
hoa chữ to lên tùy âm ông ạ nên thay đổi
đi sẽ đổi sang màu vàng này
xong rồi phun sai người to lên kiểu nhằm
nhấn mạnh không ạ chúng ta link virus
này ấy kêu thế này cái nhìn
cái này trông thấy so với cũ từ thời nào
ấy ạ
ở
đây sau đó thì giống như mình vừa nói
các bạn hoàn toàn thể đổi ý
khi đổi sang kiểu đổi thêm cả linh đã
được bấm bấm rồi Như này có thể được
ngồi cho nó đúng ạ
sẽ là thuộc tính Vista như thế này sẽ là
do sự mình cho nó là kiểu một màu à
thường đi cái kiểu thế này đã sửa mình
có hai đường Linh á sự đây là Google
virus chặn ạ
bây giờ xuống dạng đi
Hãy kiểu Nga Linh chưa được bấm nó ạ
Linh bấm rồi
em bấm rồi nó sẽ có bầu nhưng mình chưa
được Bấm thì màu nó sẽ mặc định màu xanh
thấy kiểu thế
ấy thì các bạn sẽ thấy nó hai chấm như
này sau đó là một cái gì đó gọi là code
đấy cậu chậm cội không nhớ cách viết của
nó làm đâu mà ông xem lại nhé
TC sale đâu gì đấy CS pccc đô class này
như thế này sau đó thì mấy ông có thể
tham khảo qua ở trên trang này
thì ông sẽ thấy đây toàn bộ với sữa Đâu
của nó là khi mà khi và nick nick vào nó
cũng có thể màu đó đây ở đây ông thấy
tôi Click vào nó chẳng hiển thị gì đúng
không Tôi thử click là cho xem nhé Thì
anh tít này
khi ra sự là nó sẽ đổi sang màu kiểu
Oppo này màu u
ở đó mà không thấy đổi màu sĩ nào hãy
Kiểu thế à
a
slide của tôi là lấy từ trang web
address Line này là một phần là cũng mà
từ trường cũng là em thôi Mày không chia
sẻ được cho bé ông cái giờ việc lại
slide này chẳng nói thẳng là lấy từ mình
phải Trang copy từ mới cái trang Kiểu
như đặt school này về thì ra là các bạn
Hà lên trên đây còn hơn đọc mũi sline
của tôi tôi có bờ tôi dậy đến trường Rồi
chồng dạy con schleich thì méo không cần
quan tâm điều đấy đâu
ờ ờ Các bạn thấy ở trên này có rất nhiều
nữa ngồi tôi sẽ không chạy hết tất cả
đúng này không quá à Ừ tôi không được
dạy hết một cái gì đó như thế đâu
bà Tôi chỉ khuyên mày ông tôi thích nhất
cái này Nốt này và cái selector là này
tí thôi sẽ dạy cho ông béo paper sẽ dậy
luôn mấy ông về cái selecto nhé đi
ạ Bây giờ giả sử là bơ bỏ qua vụ thời a
mấy ông nhớ thẻ à nhé bỏ qua nhé Ok tạm
xóa hết đi này ạ
anh phải đi nè
anh có giả sử tôi có ba ngày nút đi
có một cái nút đầu sẽ là nó có thai đúng
là ướt Tân Nghĩa là là là nút Thôi ngủ
mà nó chẳng có ý nghĩa gì nữa
đây là nút bình thường thì chị Yến
đúng không tiếp theo mình sẽ có một cái
nút nữa nó không bình thường mà lắm đó
là
khi bị nút là nút em ít
đây là nút để thực hiện hành động
thì đó đúng à Gửi cái Fami đúng ạ
em
thừa về đồng ý mày thừa thì sẽ đi thôi
đúng không ạ Các bạn thấy là giấu vàng
thường cái gì đó htl nó không được báo
lỗi thiếu cái gì họ không vào lỗi cháu
qua có thể nói chuyện thì sai rồi có thể
rồi Đúng bạn Các bạn thấy vừa rồi nó cho
nhìn gì sai mình không nhận ra được đấy
Đây là cái nút để thực hiện hành động
thì các bạn thấy à hai nút này chả khác
gì nhau cả và cuối cùng thêm người nút
nữa đúng ạ nút này nút reset thì bạn để
xóa anh động
hoặc khôi phục hành động thì gì đó đúng
không ạ Các bạn thấy ba ngày nút này
đang để giống hệt nhau thành ra là kiểu
người dùng nhìn thấy rất dễ bấm nhầm vào
một trong ba lúa này vậy khi người dùng
thực đôi khi để màu nhanh hơn về việc là
để ý chữ ở trên cái nút thành ra là bây
giờ mà tôi để cái nút này màu đỏ và nút
này màu xanh này và khi mày người ta bấm
sử cái nút màu xanh Nếu bấm nút màu đỏ
nâu đỏ thường anh thể hiện sự nguy hiểm
mà không ạ
anh em thành ra là bây giờ để mình nếu
mà làm như thế này gần như bài cũ thì
mới ông sẽ để cho nó cứ class đúng không
ạ class cái gì đó ID gì đó thực ra là
thế cũng được hoặc cả Bây giờ mình sẽ
kết hợp với selector tất cả sao mình sẽ
cùng là nốt mặt cùng một bát tuần nữa
ông ạ Mình sẽ có thay bằng bút Tân chẳng
hạn Cái này là nhảy đơn mà máy quét tụi
mấy ông nhắn Tôi bảo ở trong này không
quan trọng Lợi đơn Lợi kép lắm Ờ
mình sẽ có bác rau color ạ là màu lúc
bình thường rồi cái À đó chị có màu bình
thường thôi cửa màu trắng hoặc màu
gì đó như này màu ra à cổ bình thường
màu gì nhỉ
sản phẩm Một bình thường chẳng biết màu
hồng đi
ở đó
a
tiếp theo là
mình về cái nút sắp ít thì mình không
thể để chúng màu được đúng không ạ Chị
sẽ phải để màu của cái nút hành động là
nút kém nút hộ hôm Triệu Hồi trước mình
từng nói qua về cái nút call to Action
Nhã thực hiện hành động ạ thì cái nút
này nào thứ nhất là màu phải có tí thể
hiện là kiểu nó hành động thành công
theo kiểu là màu xanh lá cây màu xanh
dương
mồ à Nói chung gồm với cái màu cậu nó
nổi nhưng mà nó không mang nghĩa tiêu
cực lắm
cho ví dụ giả sử như là màu Aqua 1 tráng
dương
ở đó như này hoặc màu xanh lá cây
như thế này và đương nhiên là đang ví dụ
thể màu nói hơi xấu ra các bạn vì sau
các bạn có giao diện màu đẹp hơn sặc sỡ
hơn rất nhiều Mình đang ví dụ ở thế tiếp
theo nữa nút reset với xét là để kiểu
như thế này thì nó giống mà nút bình
thường không tốt mình sẽ nên có một nút
cho thể hiện một cảnh báo nó là sự như
này đi đồ ngoại đấy thì đây nó là
spectre các bạn sẽ thấy là
thế hệ cú pháp sợi tơ ở xã kiểu mọc nhọn
như ngày sau khi tên của thuộc tính nó
biển ngay shop các bạn sẽ thắc mắc là
hết Nếu giả sử của em có nhiều thuộc
tính ở trong mày thì sao mà sự là mình
sẽ có thai thù cho nọ cậu cùng là hai
nút bình thường em một cái là bình
thường và thay thơm một cái là cậu bình
thường hay Ví dụ ở đâu nhé
và ông chỉ muốn là cho một cái nút bình
thường hay nói màu xanh và màu hồng còn
bình thường một thì không trò này thì
công sẽ thấy ghi hay thổ thêm ở trong
như thế này bằng tiếp
Ừ thôi không nhớ là biết này đúng hay
không thử sự thử thì biết họ ạ
Ừ anh có vẻ nha Không đúng như phải như
này
đó Thì có ông sẽ thấy là kiểu nói chuyện
ra là thêm cái mỏ nhọn thêm nhầm thêm
những mặt vuông đó ạ ngon thêm dấu ngoặc
vuông sau đó thì mình sẽ tiếp cái thuộc
tỉnh nữa tiếp theo để mà mình gán chuẩn
cho đúng cái mà mình muốn hồi không ạ
Đấy
Ừ thì các bạn sẽ thấy à Đây là theo kiểu
selector tất cả chọn Cụ thể một cái gì
đó đóng ngoặc
ở lại thế thôi
ừ ừ
anh không Mình đã nói không bài toán về
đặt ID các bạn sẽ thấy là về đặc biệt là
về giao diện nút này thường ở một người
ta cho class giống như các bạn biết bút
tre thì có bạn sẽ biết được là nó thường
hay có class burton xong ngồi bất Tân
sắp xít nghĩa là kiểu thể hiện thành
công nó có tên banjo thể hiện kéo cảnh
báo thì nó sẽ là cái class thôi là ai đi
nhưng mà cảnh sợi tơ này mình đang ngoài
qua thế để các bạn phải sau không phải
để áp dụng cái này trong CF đâu Thì có
sợi tơ này là một cái phù hợp để bảo vệ
sau các bạn làm cho cả về bên ra Swift
nữa Swift sẽ viết theo kiểu sợi tơ như
thế này về mà chọn Cụ thể một cái thẻ
nào đó khi mà các bạn không phải tốn
công bạt mái đi vì đô thị Tôi nói thẳng
với ông đôi khi ông đã phải đi Mày cũng
chả nhớ tên của bé đi ấy là gì đâu về
cái nút này hai cái nút này thì mới Ông
định đã đi như thế nào
nút bình thường hay ạ ông ạ
em được mấy ông có thể chơi theo kiểu là
kiểu thằng bút tuần thứ bao nhiêu thì
bao nhiêu được Nói chung có nhiều cách
để giải quyết một vấn đề mà đúng ạ
ở đó Nói chung nhà kiến thức hôm nay thì
các bạn thấy ạ Cũng tương đối hiểu hiểu
na ná rồi có thể không nhớ mà có thể
hiểu nó nào rồi
ờ ờ Nếu mà bây giờ bây giờ mới sang bài
tập thực sự bài tập hôm nay mình sẽ phải
làm bài bài này
ờ ờ
ở đây tôi hôm nay tôi chạy hướng dẫn các
ông làm chỉ là menu thôi và bài tập cuối
ngày cuối của cái xe này đù ngon nếu như
là tổng hợp lại mình sẽ làm một trang
web như hôm trước tôi nói có thể làm một
trang web mạng xã hội nào đó cũng được
mấy ông sẽ tổng hợp những cái kiến thức
Mình đã học mình đã biết càng tốt Nó
ngoan để làm một cái trang web
công thích bất kỳ chẳng quay gì cũng
được về mấy ông bang lên kênh thích cái
bồ để mấy ông ạ
đưa nhà Đăng không phải một cái ảnh
không ạ Nếu không đi Đang nha link get
hát để để mà
tôi thể vào xem xem mấy ông thực sự gõ
mấy cái đấy Hai đứa mày đi cốt ở đâu về
nhìn có chuyên nghiệp hay cốt bình
thường bên nay đi
thế thì kiếm thì mấy ông
đấy đấy sẽ bài tập của mấy ông đó là
kiểu làm hẳn lại một cái giao diện chỉ
cần một trang HTML rồi nhé Kết hợp với
CS để mà làm ra đồng giao diện mà ông
cảm thấy ổn còn ngọn ạ
e100 bất kỳ
ngồi code của mấy ông không khóm à
chuyên nghiệp trừ khi mày ông cậu chơi
kiểu spud vào đây dọa tôi
anh nói chúc bà bây giờ tôi sẽ hướng dẫn
mấy ông làm cái Menu kem thường là bơi
ít hàng hả máy nuôi theo kiểu như này
những cô có hướng dẫn với ông bản chất
là mấy ông thấy đó hả Khi trỏ chuột ở
đây thì cái cái chữ nó sang màu đỏ chữ
to lên này bạn nền của cái này thay đổi
không ạ Thế ăn nên cái này đơn giản vì
cái nền là nó cái ảnh đấy ạ bác limeade
thì mình mình mình sẽ thử làm nhé
à à
Ừ
cái này bạn nếu mày ông Để ý kỹ người ta
Cái này nó là cái thế bồ này
đương nhiên là thường mới là chẳng ai
làm bánh ngu thì cậu thấy bồ cả nhưng mà
tôi đang chạy qua mày không phải như thế
thế Bồ đây và thấy cái chữ này in đậm
này tao nó giữa này thì nó sẽ th đúng
không ạ Mình sẽ tr từng tr và chỉ có một
th thôi nghe sẽ thể loại phim này
tiếp theo là Tarot tiếp này
TD này hành động ở
a kinh dị người lớn nhỏ ạ
cô
không Mấy ông không được dùng bút chép
hay di li càng không mùi rõ làm thôi Chị
nói với ông được làm hlcs không không
không chơi được à bút chát không chơi
Facebook gì nhiều nhé á
Ừ
đấy rõ ràng mấy ông Định Smart tôi rồi
tôi biết mà
không được
đây nếu mà chạy thử cái này mấy ông sẽ
thấy nó ra như này rất nhạt nhẽo đóng
ngoặc tí nữa để làm ra được trong chậu
như này thì đầu tiên là các bạn phải
chỉnh cho Mắm cái cái cái bàn này đang
cái vít của nó đang còn 100 không ạ Mình
chỉ quýt nó
style cho nó luôn đấy cũng được trăm
phần trăm kè Nếu mà Mấy ông muốn nằm
ngang như thế này thôi nhá
đó Tiếp theo là cái này như tôi đã nói
bạn chất mấy cái này đều là backgroud
hết bác limeade những để chỉnh nhanh cho
nó nó là với cái th đấy với thẻ th mình
sẽ có bác rau inmates L cho nó 1 cái ảnh
không ạ Anh ở đây của tôi là cái ảnh nó
Ừ nó nên nó đậm
thật sự không nhớ ảnh gì luôn xem thử
xem ạ
ờ ờ
em copy đường dẫn này
Em
đổi cái này thành
Suốt này thì nó mới nhận này
Khoa
học Xã hội Suốt này à
Anh thử nha à
ở
đó chắc là được cho là đúng đấy tiếp
theo là tôi có PD đúng không ạ ạ
ở
bến xe lấy nốt cái ảnh ở trên này à
Sau
đó các bạn sẽ thấy thời gian nó hơi khó
chịu một ý nghĩa vì nó bị thừa khỏi
trống ở đây đó nhà thì cái để mà mình
chỉ trỏ đẻ chọn inspect này mình kiểm
sau đó thì mình à đây cho bạn xem
Vì mình thấy có khoảng trống ở đây Tại
sao tại sao nó cũng hỏi trống ở đây xem
kỹ nhé
vì nó có cái bát đinh một này nhớ là mặc
định nó đang cách với cái lề
để tạo ra khoảng trống ở ngoài mình hoàn
toàn thì mình chỉnh cho nó kiểu tránh bị
từ đấy mình sẽ để cho dụ
cho tác cả thằng này vẫn không ai đều
bọc eding đi đã đây là không ạ
Em đỡ ai nhớ cái này không đúng Đợi mình
thích nhưng không đúng không em
Ừ bắt đình này không không không phải
đâu như cái bò đâu đấy
Ừ để mình xem kỹ lại nhé
em không nhớ về vụ này lắm đó
a Tale lồ này
ở Bắc Ninh
Ừ đúng rồi nhỉ
a Model
em có khi mình nói xem lại cái này Tại
sao nó được như này đấy
ở tt background
đó là sage Bắc Ninh đúng là xe Bắc Ninh
trình cho từng từng Cái ô này cách nhau
nữa Đúng rồi quên đấy mình sẽ thay bồ
này
siêu bá tinh này
đã không ạ
Ừ đúng nhỉ
à à
em à cái ghi thẳng ở trong thuộc tính
Giống nhờ kiểu HCl C
trong CS thì chả có thôi mình không nhớ
nó là cái gì có tạm copy đấy nhá và
spurs
spacing này Ok này
những kẻ thống trị như các bạn đang thấy
có thể mình chưa biết được cái này bởi
vì vốn dĩ À cái này mình chỉ đang làm
cho các bạn biết qua thôi Thực ra là
cái này mình chỗ được áp dụng ngoài
ngoài thực tế bây giờ thành ra mình
chẳng biết chịu không không không nhớ nó
là cái gì cả
a
Marine không đúng đâu bị marquezine rồi
nó không phải mặt Magie nó trống đấy ạ
10 cái đấy không ạ chôm cốt đâu vì
koastal Eco tự mình gõ ra mà nhưng mà
chẳng qua là mấy năm trước rồi
ở ngã tự mình chung cốt của mình
à à
Ừ
đấy thì các bạn sẽ thấy nó là giống rồi
nhưng mà rõ ràng là Đây chưa phải là thẻ
a nên thành ra là nó không kiểu chỉ vào
để mà trông có vẻ bấm được như này kết
hợp với việc là ở
yêu cầu các bạn phải nền nó thay đổi đối
ngoại thực ra là đứt khi một là các bạn
không cần làm thẻ các bạn chỉ cần làm
hiệu ứng thôi Chứ người ta không bấm
được cũng là một cái cách để ngoài như
bây giờ mình cứ làm theo chuẩn chuẩn đi
sử dụng cái spectre mình vừa học đi
có gì sẽ đẩy đổi đây thẻ này
mà đây sẽ à hf cho nó thăng các bạn
thường hay thấy hạt lép đôi khi là một
cái thằng như thế này
Ừ chị đã giản là bởi vì à tạm thời không
biết đẩy nó đi đâu Và không không muốn
bấm nhảy sang lại trang web khác thì tạm
để nó như thế này để khi bấm nó vẫn có
vẻ bấm được đưa ra là chỉ là chẳng để ý
đâu cả đấy thì thường khó trang web mới
thường anh sự thăng Hiểu ngay ý
thì các bạn thấy nó đang rất khó chịu
cái này tôi không thích cái này đâu
ngoại thì mình thể
link này mình sẽ đổi đổi vẫn giữ nguyên
màu cũ này vẫn màu hoa này trả nợ thế
Thế mình xóa này đi nhá
đi hát đây để đạt được hãy cho mình sẽ
tách đi Collagen sẽ à năm bỏ cái and
like đi các bạn sẽ thấy là cái này thì
thẻ không bấm được đầy thế bấm được đấy
ạ ạ
ừ ừ
ờ ờ
em lấy tiếp theo là mình
đợi Đợi mình tí
có bố mẹ mình đến à
thì alo
mình đang ở đâu
Ừ mình đang thuê nhà ở riêng thì da dầu
bố mẹ để đốt mục loạn một tí Con chó thì
con chó mình nó hơi bị ngu mình tí Nó
sủa tất cả ý
à à
anh alo cho ạ Vẫn chưa ông là áo mai
nghỉ Okay tiếp nhá Khi cái này muốn đổi
cho nó sang kiểu khác thì dùng a server
thôi đúng ạ
Em
à mình sẽ cho nó care là last này
thế này và cho nó kiểu chữ nó đậm lên đi
đúng ạ là thôn huyết này
bồn này khi mà chỉ vào chữ sẽ đậm hơn
này đó xong rồi mình có thể trách say
Vậy à Đâu phần sai không sai cho nó sẽ
to lên là sự 20 hết đó Nhưng mà các bạn
phải nền nó còn thay đổi được đúng không
Thế là sao mình sẽ cho nó cả bác ra
winmate này oll xong rồi cho nó những
cái ảnh nó thể kiểu đổi đổi khi mà trỏ
chuột vào lại cái Server này ạ
à à
ở
đó nhớ mà các bạn thấy là ở đây nó nó
hơi sai sai một tí đúng ạ Các bạn thấy ở
đây là cả cái cả cái ô nhé không phải là
cái Hà nó nhé các bạn để ý kĩ là cả cái
ô rồi khi rõ là một ở đây đang chiếm cả
cái hàng nhưng bản chất đây là cả kéo
vui thôi Nó đang được đổi chứ không phải
là
mình muốn đổi cho cái bát rau cho cái
mỗi chữ đối ngoại thì cái làm như thế
nào Cái này là khi mà cái cái thẻ mà nó
được vu vơ thì cái thằng cha nó sẽ được
thay đổi đúng ạ ra xong TD thì các bạn
sẽ phải TD xong rồi ahaha vơ như thế này
nghĩa là đây đây là mở - AV đúng không ạ
thì nó sẽ đổi backgroud
Ừ đúng nhỉ
khi cài đặt hình như bị ngược lại đợi
mình thấy ngược lạ á
em ở đâu đâu đâu không khó không Nghĩa
là chỉ cần tới đây hoa vợ rồi thì phải
bệnh tim I ở đó như thế này ừ ừ
Ừ cái này cũng được không ạ
em hết đồ rồi thì các bạn sẽ thấy à
Ừ ừ
hình nhờ Đợt này là mình làm nữa
chỉ cần tới đê
đây đây đây hoover rồi Thằng A là thay
đổi cũng được không ạ mình Nếu mình làm
cái cái này thì nó sẽ ngược lại thôi nó
sẽ là khi TD hoover này thì tới đây họ
vợ nhé Thì thằng A nó thay đổi này nó sẽ
như thế này copy toàn bộ này xuống dưới
thôi I
Hồ Ngọc Như nhau cả
chả qua là bây giờ là mình TD bị ho vơ
và TD luôn Mình không cần Harvard và thẻ
nữa đấy nó sẽ như thế này
ở đó
ở đâu chưa
ở trong ổn mà đúng không ạ
xe tải
ở đây không phải là cái Menu mà các bạn
thường máy Thấy bây giờ để cho mình dậy
đó các bạn hai cái meru mà các bạn
thường ai gặp thường hay gặp thôi đó tôi
sẽ dùng Chính hai đối thủ cạnh tranh đó
là án phát ký
D10 mua cả hai chị chai cái tôi nhỏ
có một cái là menu theo kiểu là ông chị
Đây là lúc đầu nó là menu dọc mà béo để
kia ông nói mày ngu dọc này đấy nhưng mà
khi chỉ chuột và từng cái thì nó sẽ hiển
thị xanh cái ở bên phải nó sẽ mandu kéo
nó vẫn tính làm nên ngu dọc nha Trả qua
mày menu nó mới nó khai cấp thức à Chỉ
vào nó sẽ chị ram cấp con và nó nữa làm
bánh phạt
đấy tiếp theo là một cái một ông nữa Ông
Hà Nội Computer
ông này thì
bây giờ nó đổi sang rọc mà
mình nhớ hồi trước có để nhanh rồi nghỉ
ở
anh bắt chước nhau
ở đây ông mày vẫn còn cái nha này tôi
tôi dùng hôm nay vậy nha đây ông có thấy
à Ở trên này nó vẫn là menu ở trên vẫn
là nhanh được nhé Chỉ vào nó để thị dọc
xuống đây đưa mà Đấy thì mình sẽ mình sẽ
dạy các bạn về cái vụ à
dịch vụ làm được menu treo chiều dọc
trước bởi vì nó dễ hơn sau đó mình đôi
theo chiều ngang để bọn
khi
gà nói thế thì bây giờ mới Ông chẳng ông
nào đi ngồi làm menu thuần thuần nữa Nếu
không đi có sự giao diện về đóng anh đã
hướng dẫn như thế
ở tiên là mình sẽ có ul lời đi này rồi
nha yêu em nói họ Oh Ly Tùy các bạn hãy
cho kẻ này
cũng sẽ giống như kiểu này đi theo ngoại
hành động này à
a
kinh dị này ạ ừ ừ
ở người lớn ạ
Mình chạy thử lại nha
đây Thế bây giờ đang chưa Bấm được này
mình sẽ cho nó 1 cái
đều cho nó cái Hz thì nó để nó có thể
bấm được đi
à
Các bạn thấy cái Menu như thế này chẳng
có trang web hợp Tìm kiếm cái ngu kiểu
xấu xấu ngày đúng không ạ Thế bây giờ
mình muốn làm cho kiểu menu trở nên màu
mè thôi cả lại nói hiển thị ở châu rọc
Thôi bỏ vào đấy nó sẽ hiển thị ra Ví dụ
là
kỳ dị này có yếu tố đây giờ sự là thêm
cả
từ nhỏ không Ba mẹ để nó Ngoài ra trong
nha
mình nhưng ở ngoài này Google một kẻ lý
và lời y tiếp này
cái A tiếp này
là yếu tố hài hước ra ngoài đi
và yếu tố đây là
tình cảm của ngài đi
đấy thì thì bây giờ mình muốn là kiểu
lúc đầu đây là menu gọi menu 2 cấp đúng
không ạ nghĩa là có thằng cha này thằng
con này đúng không ạ Và mình muốn à đầu
tiên là mình sẽ xóa đi toàn bộ nhưng cái
kiểu giấu Mấy cái biểu tượng ở đằng
trước này đi này kết hợp việc là mình
khi mà Lúc đầu thì cái thằng con nó sẽ
ẩn đi mình trỏ chuột vào thằng cha thì
nó mới nhịn đi thằng con khi làm như thế
nào để bọn nó tin là mình phải ẩn đi
toàn bộ những cái
ly này Thảo ul thôi cũng phải display I
ris play outside Tuynel
đó bây giờ ẩn đi những cái tưởng tượng
rồi đúng ạ
tiếp theo là mấy ông thấy thử làm bài
toán được cái thằng này nó cũng bị đó là
nó đang cách mặc định nó cách vào khoảng
như này tôi muốn bỏ cái cái cái đi mình
sẽ có mặc định bát tinh bằng không sẽ bỏ
đi đỏ như này Nếu bỏ đi thì đồng nghĩa
việc là nếu không thấy nó đang bị như
này trong một khó chịu đầu tiên mình cần
thế thằng con đi thằng con đấy đúng
không ạ thường là nếu thế thì tôi thường
anh đặt ID thằng cha để mà Ẩn Hoàng Con
gì nó dễ hoặc là mấy ông đi hẳn hẳn như
thế này l lời này ul tiếp này thì beat
mai là năm và sẽ là ngon quá đi này
ý nghĩa thằng cha này gọi đến thằng con
này và gọi đến thằng con nữa thì sẽ ở nó
đi như thế này đấy ông ạ
khi reset CF
ẩm thực cả mấy ông mấy hôm nay nhắc đến
ri sexy nó cũng chả hiểu lý sách sẽ trả
lời gì cả thì tôi thử tra xem
displace để ẩn nào đi Như thế này đều
ngoạn đấy tiếp theo nữa đó là mấy ông
muốn trỏ chuột vào thì nó ảnh hiển thị
ra thì thế nào đúng không ạ
thì mình sẽ là ở mỗi với mỗi nồi ý khi
mà ho vơ vào thì euler sẽ ít lây là blog
là thì chị ra cản
đó hay không này
và bây giờ Ông mấy ông có thể hoàn toàn
thêm những cái yếu tố kiểu đẹp hơn làm
như là mình sẽ cho nó 1 cái background
color là màu hồng đi
xong ngồi
chữ là màu đỏ
rồi
khách đi coi chừng bỏ đi thẳng a
âm mưu trên wii cho cái này chỉ là 200
mét thôi 3 Đây là một
Souls II a black Đà Nẵng
vào như thế này
Anh chỉ bảo nói ra nhưng mà cái và Toán
chỉ và hiển thị ra này nó sẽ gây khó
chịu cho bé ông của thì tôi muốn nó chui
sang bên này cơ không phải chui ra như
thế này không ạ Cái bao đời này đang hơi
dính dính với nhau
bother này nó đang bị đè lên nhau nên
nói chung càng giá ngay đúng ạ Mình có
thể chỉnh cho nó tách ra một tí nó mắc J
nói gì đó
thì tại sao tự nhiên tôi phải đi cập
Border đấy thì tí mấy ông sẽ hình dung
được việc là nó đang chiếm bao nhiêu bao
nhiêu bể quý cả các thứ thứ ạ
Ừ nhưng mà cái này đang rình cái này nó
đang bị đè với nhau chúng cảm giác khó
chịu nghỉ mình có thể là
mecghi mắt Model I
ở đâu đấy xem nhé
[âm nhạc]
nhớ rồi đấy làm như thế nào đấy mình có
làm ở đây rồi
Trông cái này không phải đỡ À đấy tôi
làm cái bạn này như thế nào nhỉ Đợi xin
phép một phút thì xem lại không nhớ lấy
đi làm nhà luôn ly
a Google thôi thử xem ạ này
lâu rồi tôi không làm chúng cặp
vẫn thế mà bị bắt
à à
nhà
xe mạnh nha à
a mother
em bỏ qua Võ Xuân lifegoeson Tím Minh
triệu rồi
phim hài
Ê biết à
em
có gửi cho nó 1 cái hay đi 50 Tết Ừ đúng
rồi đúng rồi nó sát vào nhau rồi mà mình
chỉ hay cho nó khách ra thì nó sẽ không
bị dính vào nhau nữa
là lâu nó vẫn thế mà vì rồi mình sẽ cho
nó bị rồi à
à à
a
color Black của tôi đang không có này
không ạ
ừ ừ
khi
con đơn này phải đi đè và cái A nó không
ạ
này năn số ít
À nó chịu rồi chưa hiểu tại sao nó có nó
cái đèn nhau nha tạm bỏ qua đi đã Em
à nhớ Bây giờ cứ tạm bỏ qua vụ bother
bây Làm thế nào để cho nó sẽ sang bên
phải của cái này như vừa rồi Các bạn có
thấy qua người mẫu được ra là mình sẽ
chỉnh cái này là có reason nhớ một con
Sơn nó nhọn sau đó thì thằng này sẽ làm
cha thằng con nó sẽ nổi hiển thị lên
nhưng mà cách thằng cha ở bên phải trở
lại không ạ
Nó sẽ là ờ
mỗi ngày sẽ có Sơn là Huế tiếp
thứ ba thằng ngày Khi mà được kế thừa
Khi mà gọi ra được nghe nó
Google họ đến nơi dai covers thế này thì
thằng này phố sơn nó sẽ là a absolute
trở lại à
th2 sẽ à day là sự cách right 200pf này
à
thì trừ 200 kế
đó nó như thế này bạn thấy được gà Nó bị
nó bị một tí ở đây bởi vì À cái này nó
liên quan đến ba đây nữa bộ đồ nó là bao
đời Trái bộ đội phải làm cho nó bị rách
da như thế này thì mình sẽ phải là 202
nóng sẽ được đó như này và đương nhiên à
Vì nó có thêm một tí ở đây nữa nên là
mấy ông ngoại cắm trình căn chỉnh tí cho
đẹp à
chỉ đứng ngắm nhìn giao diện thôi thì
mày Ông cố tuần nếu không bị nó hỏi nó
đẹp được cả chỉ là mức tương đối thôi
Ừ thì mấy ông sẽ thấy là nó sẽ cách như
này thì mấy ông Chị có thể có có thể
chơi bằng cách này đây à
Mở bài nhạc hàng ngày đúng không ạ
ờ ờ ờ
à à
thì
mình sẽ cho một cái đây là tốp là
3 - 10 pack à
à à Ô
thế hạnh - 10 rồi nghỉ đợi vậy Tí hình
như không đấy hả - 10
Anh Phan định chỉ em béo mà có thể thay
rồi cái gì 10 ngay ở trong clip tu này
nè Nhưng có vẻ cái hồ vơ nó không thì
chị ra hơi khó lấy cho mình cứ phải giảm
dần làm nhân vật thể
ở đó - 2 - 2 cái này đúng rồi đấy Chẳng
qua là do cái này là nó bị đè lên cái bò
đơn nên chồng có thấy đâu nhé á Ừ thôi
thì Dạy vẽ ở mức tương đối mà đúng ạ
Cái này vừa rồi tôi còn nói qua đó là
ông đang bị Tuy là ông để cho cái ly nó
là mộ màu đỏ nhưng mà như tôi từng nói
đó là thằng nào gần gần nó hơn họ sẽ ghi
đè CF lên hơn thằng thẻ a này nó gần hơn
Xóa Thằng lời dai nên hành gia nó vẫn
ghi đè CS của thằng Thế lên một là ông
ghi đè hẳn CS của thằng thể A2 là không
phải thêm importance vào trong này để
cho nó ghi đè lên tất cả những cái thằng
khác không có đi vào tân đấy thì ông có
thể hoàn toàn ghi vào thìa như thế này
cũng được color-les và thaek bị coi
chừng là năm như thế này hay gì ở đây
thì nó sẽ làm mất đi thế này nó cho nó
cũng đỡ hơn rồi mà nó không ạ
Em bấm vào chưa có vở Tôi chưa thử ngủ
đãi về theo tôi mà phát Đấy nói chung
nhà vừa rồi chỉ cho các bạn Ngang Qua về
việc làm menu menu
dọc đường ạ Cái có mấy nung anh phải ra
mày ngủ nhanh thì ra chỉnh theo đúng như
cái form này nó cũng nhanh thôi
đây tôi thể
Ừ vậy thì chị méo Nhanh nhá Còn chắc là
vẫn thể giữ nguyên tất cả đúng này nhá Ừ
à à
thì
mình cứ xóa đỡ đầu tiên là tôi muốn cho
cái này nó sang ngang đã đúng ạ thì
thường là tôi sẽ chơi cái trò nó là
flash nép mình sẽ trôi hết tất cả cái
bản chất là từng cái lồi này sợi đít nó
sẽ display-block cái Vlog này này là sẽ
đẩy thằng khác xuống dòng cái cái
display-block này có nhiều thẻ nó sẽ con
display-block có nhiều thẻ dispray nó
lại in life in like thức à nó sẽ vẫn nằm
trong cùng một rằng Đấy cùng đồ lót thì
nó sẽ nó thêm nó giống hiểu thêm một cái
Basel đấy để giúp sáng kia nhảy xuống
dòng những cái thằng với những hàng like
thì các bạn từng thấy rồi nó lại bị biết
nó thấy Maria này phải spam này có thể
dịch nha Em hãy input này lại là khi hòa
thể gót chân này không ạ khi mà các bạn
sử dụng sang thẻ này các bạn thấy hoàn
toàn là nó vẫn nó vẫn không xuống dòng
các bạn phải thêm PR để nó xuống gặp con
những cái mặc định nó sẽ giúp chúng ta
với Như ạ Các Thẻ H1 H2 H3 này đúng
không ạ thẻ thấy bồ này form này thẻ
Em đừng như thế bây rồi chắc chắn xuống
thôi à Còn thể diện nhé
thẻ đúng ngoài thể lấy này đúng không ạ
à còn gì nhỉ
anh ấy lại Thái Tôi nhớ Thế hả đúng
không phải tên nữa quan trọng bên đấy
thì những thẻ này khi mà đúng rồi phải
đít nữa nhỉ những cái thẻ này khi mà nó
đóng xong ấy nó sẽ luôn đẩy khác xuống
dòng và các bạn nhớ đặc biệt cái thẻ đi
uống trước các bạn nhớ để mà nó cùng nằm
trên cùng một dòng thì các bạn sẽ phải
flashless
đúng rồi in like thiếu và cái a nữa Khi
mà đóng thể là các bạn thấy nó vẫn nằm
trên cùng một dòng đúng ạ
tôi là lúa tục không nhớ hết rồi
thì vợ mình muốn cho cái lỗ ý khi mà
nhớ ở mình chỉ muốn cho cái này nó xuống
dòng thôi Còn cái còn cái thang này vẫn
Dự là cái tháng ngày không xuống dòng
còn thằng này vẫn sẽ xuống lòng ấy thì
mình chỉ có
cool gọi đến lợi y
anh như này ra sự flash kép nhé là cho
nó cũng nằm trên cùng một dòng này
anh đợi mình đi lấy đó
à à
khi đó nó sẽ như này
Anh chỉ vào này
có nên sang chợ giờ này chỉ vào các bạn
thấy à nó sẽ
nó đang top như thế này thành ra bị bị
nhảy không ạ thì trong trường hợp này
mình lại phải chỉnh lại một tí
a picture này vẫn vẫn thế là lần này
Like nó không nghe ngày nữa mà mình
chỉnh top
dụng là
ở top sẽ là
U50 bếp chẳng hạn
số 52 52 -
5 Út à à
U22 51 ở chỗ Quảng Trị tương đối được
ngay thôi ông ạ và các bạn thấy được ra
nó vẫn còn cái dính tí ba đây cái thử
nữa nó đương nhiên ở đây đang ví dụ thôi
Thường mấy ông chẳng chưa portal.dau thì
mới ông sẽ cắm cái này nó sẽ khá khớp
không ạ
đó thì các bạn thấy là một khi mà làm
cái Menu dọc song đội xong daruma chỉ
cần thêm cái flashless là xong
nhớ rõ rồi còn BT cốt mấy ông hoàn toàn
thể xem tham khảo lại để làm
anh hả Mà ông đã nghe được karaoke hàng
xóm của tôi hai mấy ông đang than phiền
cái karaoke hàng xóm nhà ông ấy
ừ ừ
ẩm thực tế thì cái này không liên quan
một tí nhưng thực tế là tôi từ mới khỏi
gọi 113 thì xử lý hàng xóm
tử vi hàng xóm hát Quá ồn nửa đêm và
mấy ngày liền như thế không hiểu Nó kiểu
Liên Hoàng cái gì
Ừ thì cho ca thì các bạn cái này cái bài
toán yếu tố của đây đó là tôi không phải
ác thì đâu ra mấy người này có bị phạt
gì đâu tuy Phạm Chuẩn là phải pha đấy
anh Bởi vì theo luật nó thế các bạn thứ
hai Đăng Khôi bị sai việc là à
thì các bạn đương nhiên là nếu mà một
ngày như thế thôi châm chước người ta
còn nhiều ngày thật là người ta người ta
kiểu không quan tâm các bạn các bạn
chẳng cần quan tâm người ra à
vì tình cảm Nghĩa xóm Thực ra lõm ảnh
hưởng nhưng thực ra tôi thuê nhà nó cũng
chẳng nên là cũng chả liên quan gì cả
À hôm ấy tôi định quà nhắc nhở hàng xóm
ấy chứ nhưng mà người ta hát quả kho nói
từ đập cửa người ta ở không không để ý
thậm chí công an đến đập cửa gọi liên
tục 13 không để ý con cơm Công An bậc
của trường Công an đập đập cửa hơn mười
phút đồng hồ không gọi được chưa Thế
thì ông phải hiểu rằng người ta đang hát
nó như nào không quan tâm Trời đất gì cả
kệ luôn á
Ừ thì
thực Hà nói qua một tí vụ đấy Đó là thứ
ra nó tính Tôi không thích làm ảnh hưởng
khác thế được là cái đấy nó liên quan để
ô nhiễm âm thanh giờ trải nghiệm không
tốt
em ở thành phố rồi này bị ô nhiễm âm
thanh tự vệ có chữ ạ ạ
à à Ừ thì bây giờ 9 giờ cho các người ta
cũng cái kệ mấy ông tra Google về ô
nhiễm Thanh là thừa Đôi khi phải đến cái
tâm số bao nhiêu bao nhiêu thì nóng đó
là phạt các thứ thử cơ à
ừ ừ
em ở chỗ là đầy đủ kiến thức ngày hôm
nay ở đông lạnh bài tập thì tôi còn nói
qua rồi tôi chia sẻ chị xem tôi sẽ chia
sẻ cho mấy ông cái gì
Ê hồi trước ở tôi tìm được cái á sẽ hai
cực cái HTML để mà chị với cả giao diện
kiểu nó
22p cái ạ âm lượng cơ chia sẻ trong nhóm
mình rồi tôi tìm lại bài đấy không được
em chẳng nhớ là tại chết sạch
Ừ cái gì nhỉ Lưu nhớ không nhớ nó cái gì
nữa
à à
ừ ừ
sau
khi nhảy dây lành mạnh nha À à OK thực
ra cái gì đó hồi trước tôi có đọc Đó là
thức đặc biệt ở Dân công nghệ như bọn
tôi yêu thật đậm kiểu tập thể dục thì
cái vụ nhảy dây ý thì cái là nó rất là
tốt đó là kiểu nó cũng là tập thể dục
kết hợp việc à Đừng đừng Nghĩa nhảy sai
chỉ thành con gái gì đó mà nhảy dây nó
sẽ là vận động được Toàn có thể cả chân
cả tay và rất nhiều cơ như mấy ông để kỵ
đọc đọc đọc thử nghiên cứu hết thì mấy
ông sẽ thấy thế nhỉ dây nó vận động rất
nhiều cơ ông kia nó đá bóng đá bóng
không vận động cản trở cả tay đâu đúng
không ạ thì ạ
Ừ thì nhảy dây nó sẽ làm cho cơ thể Ông
vừa dẻo dai hơn vừa vận động được nhiều
cơ Cá thứ mà làm tại nhà được đúng ạ
Mình cảm thấy ạ Mấy ông nên ngoài thế
xong tự nhiên ngày hôm sau đấy
tiền tiền bán bàn về cái dây ở tăng ra à
Ê
mấy ông kia đang Đề cập về những cái môn
thể thao khác đơn nghĩa mỗi thể thao Nó
sẽ vận động theo khá nhiều đôi khi là
toàn bộ cũng kiểu nghị tương tự như thế
và nó đỡ chỉ thích hơn tình yêu Tổ thích
bơi lặn bơi khá tốt nhưng mà
nhưng mà đang nói là ông luyện tại nhà
cơ mà đúng ạ được tại nhà mấy ông một là
ông chạy bộ tại nhà hay ông những dây
hoa cả làm kiểu tập gym hoặc tập võ tại
nhà nhưng mà cho J10 võ thì cả nó này
đôi khi chuyển hướng hẳn với một cái cơ
vì đó không phải liên quan hiểu dai võ
thì còn tí dẻo dai một cứng cáp nhưng mà
nó không hiểu Nó không vận động được
toàn thân nếu mà ông không Ông không tập
toàn bộ các các động tác thế hiểu vấn đề
dây về cơ bản thì nó sẽ luôn luôn kích
thích tất cả các cơ của ông trừ khi ô
không nhỉ Không nhảy dây đúng thế thôi
xe tải Cờ Thế à
ừ ừ
a
ha bị giảm khả năng sinh con thì rung
lắc quá nhiều ạ ạ
Ê mấy ông mạnh thì đương nhiên nếu phải
mặc bộ đồ thể dục để tránh rung rồi à
ạ
Bây giờ chẳng biết chia sẻ với ông cái
gì nhỉ Dạo gần đây rồi ca tôi tôi tôi
từng nói rồi đỡ Hà môi cứ chảy về những
cái phần mềm Tôi đang dùng đi à
ở đây à
từ hôm nay sắc là mấy ông không biết từ
hôm trước rồi Chắc thế nó không thắc mắc
về cái vụ biểu tượng biểu tượng này của
tôi tượng này tôi Dũng thôi à Cũng như
không trả lời rồi cũng chưa sợ đâu rồi
dùng Cài classic sail này để mà thay đổi
tượng này
Thật ra tôi hội đấy tôi dùng thêm cái cứ
Lina này để đề mà cô ấy thích cậu dọn
rác với vùng thì về sau trận ra mình
lười quét cái này lắm
Nhưng trên này ra nó còn có người cái vụ
là kiểu Xóa dùm cái ứng dụng vì nó nhanh
đây toàn bộ những phần mềm tôi đang cày
ngoài mấy phần mềm vô số Tôi không nói
thì tôi nói qua thứ nhất ở cái cái
anydesk này cho thể ndtec này
ở gần đây có vẻ tôi và dẫn công nghệ
dùng nhiều hơn
khi dùng có vẻ tốt hơn cái Teamviewer
rồi cậu là gì
Ừ nó
Ừ thôi không biết nói nó tốt hơn về
những cái gì nữa nhưng mà tôi khuyên với
ông thử dùng qua mấy ông sẽ thế là nó
thích hơn teamview và ít nhất là nó
không đòi nó không có giới hạn thời gian
như làn teamview lỡ khó chịu được hả
Which are viewed được cho nó không giới
hạn thời gian các thứ II
ờ ờ còn gì nhé
Ừ cái cloud Phen này là để thỉnh thoảng
tôi Cậu muốn kết nối đi ra ngoài nó là
VPN để kết nối sang một cái trang Army
cái kiểu server nước ngoài
Vì vậy tôi làm việc với đội ta nước
ngoài phải mở ngày lên nó chạy cái
clownfish này tôi gần đây tôi cài để mà
thay đổi giọng gà Nó cũng chẳng thay đổi
được mấy số tưởng được cài xong giọng
rồi sẽ đến anh nữ nữ Nhưng mà không
chẳng ngọt ngào gì cả
Bởi vì tôi xem mấy cái video của mấy ông
trên blog tự nhiên kiểu đôi dặm ông ấy
kiểu đang rộng chậm năm tình ngoại rồi
thằng giọng nữ rồi sợ đi lừa với thằng
khác được cô che Vậy thì cờ thấy hay hay
với định kiểu K thể trêu bạn cuối cùng
Giọng tôi chị dành cho trò ơi buồn vãi
sao phải mất tiền của vụ này
ở nhà anh Tuấn cũng mua hẳn cái mất tiền
rồi đấy nhưng mà tôi tay thử cái đấy
cũng biến thành giọng nữa đâu cũng chẳng
ngọt ngào đấy
Ồ không Tôi đang dùng cái mic xịn như
tội trạng dùng ngay cái đấy em gì là tôi
dùng cái đấy trời xoay trai sẵn có
Ừ cái này đi bây girl này có vẻ miễn phí
mà kệ kết hợp việc là nó hỗ trợ được khá
nhiều DB này mày Ông Mười xóm cân nhắc
có cái cày cái này
A discourse thì mấy ông cho biết qua rồi
à
Ừ kệ bi sinh này nghệ bị sinh này là để
tìm kiếm một cái gì đó rất là nhanh ở
trên máy của ông Ông không cần phải chọn
thư mục bất kỳ ông chuẩn gõ tên bức Kim
wi-fi nó đó tốc độ Tìm kiếm của nó nó sẽ
nó ra nào giống như nó bánh đất toàn bộ
những cái file trên máy ông để tìm kiếm
nó sẽ nhanh hơn Tìm kiếm thông thường
bằng Windows XP is pro này rất nhiều nếu
nghịch cài này cái này nó chị chỉ trong
vòng ở đây tìm cái gì đó cho Quỳnh ra
nhé á
Anh Thương Nhiều lúc đầu nó có phải đợi
một tí vui vì ạ
thì nó đang đây là lần đầu tiên lần đầu
tiên Lâu lâu không chạy hoa cà ông không
để nó mở tự động ấy thì nó sẽ không bán
đất cho toàn bộ file
Nhưng mà nếu ông dùng thường xuyên rồi
thì nó sẽ nhanh
đời Hình như là tôi pháp sư cái tự động
chạy của nó rồi Thằng Anh nó bị đơ thì
không Bọn Phát
Nghe
đài tiếng nói tự tắt sự của nó rồi
à à
Ừ nếu mà cài cái này xong bê tông sẽ
kiểu gõ cái gì Nhận dạng xảy ra rất
nhanh đấy như thế này phải không Tôi có
gì đâu nó tìm kiếm nhanh lên đấy thì ông
sẽ thấy được là nó nhanh như thế nào
đúng
ừ ừ
thu hẹp này tôi cái ép này nó hơn cái tự
động tự động điều chỉnh cái Windows là
da nó có tự động điều chỉnh độ sáng đấy
Sáng độ sáng tiếng Anh là cái gì nhỉ
trước
a close friend à
vì
nó có chỉnh độ chế độ natri này nhưng mà
nitrites tinh của nó thực ra Nó chỉ có
mỗi
treo khoảng mặt trời mọc và mặt trời
lạnh hết Nó không chỉ theo tuần thời
gian trong ngành này tự nhiên phải nhìn
đất vậy thì sẽ tạo một cái một cái file
như một cái thư mục hay file gì đó Tìm
mã trên đất thì có pha nhấn nhẹ thôi
mình nghĩ là không ảnh hưởng gì nhiều
lắm đâu
Ờ
nó sẽ theo mốc thời gian trong ngày như
thế này Từ chỗ ông xem em nhảy nó sẽ có
rất nhiều mốc và đặc biệt ông còn có thể
tự có chỉnh nó nhưng các thứ thứ nữa
thành ra là tốt hơn so với việc tự động
của thằng Window có mỗi hợp đến bình
minh thì bảo lên hoàng hôn xuống hết rồi
nên tôi thấy mà ép này hơn
Hoài vì là để 7 để mà đẩy cốt của ông
main hosting ai cái gì đó Mạnh cũng cần
này get em thế này
I get up this popular ghi thôi
Tải Google Chrome trình duyệt tôi thấy à
về cơ bản thì gần đây tôi dùng nó vẫn
rất tự nhiên nó giật giật Chắc là cài
thêm nhiều tiện ích nhưng tôi cảm thấy ạ
Bởi vì nó có sẵn tích hợp tài khoản
Google nên là tôi vẫn ngại thay thế nó
so với thăm hết hay là thằng Cốc Cốc ạ
Ê
thằng Firefox thừa rõ ràng hả Mấy thằng
ấy có những cái điểm mạnh ghi âm
khi Internet Download Manager
ô tô mua sự bản quyền rồi người ta nó
rất là rẻ nhưng cụ mày Việt thì phải bốn
trăm rưỡi hay 500 gì đấy mà trọn đời nên
khởi nghĩa là nó cũng xứng đáng khi mình
có tiền thì mình nên mua cái này tốt để
mà tải rất nhiều cái thứ nó còn Hỗ trợ
nó giống kiểu thằng Cốc cốc cái kiểu nó
tự động gợi ý những cái để mà tải video
hay à Hay nhạc gì đó A lagon để mày ông
với 6 chốt này à
Ừ cái Logitech option để mà cho phù hợp
cho một cái cái chuột Hình như từng nói
qua rồi một con chuột đầy nút của tôi về
thôi chỉnh cho rất nhiều cái nút ở trên
chuột tôi Thành rất nhiều đây còn cho
tôi đang dụng này thì ông sẽ thấy nó có
rất nhiều cái nút để thể bấm vào và tôi
cấu hình hết cho nó dụ lại bấm bấm nút
này mở
tắt cái cửa sổ này đi này sạc cửa sổ
xuống ăn gì đó chúng rất là ngon
gì hết này tôi vẫn chưa gỡ này à
Ê mày Cái này đưa ra mặc định của
Ê mày cái này tôi nói qua mấy Ông Nếu
mấy ông không biết mày mấy cái SQL
Server này
Anh
thật là mấy cái C + + này nhiều hồi
trước chính tôi là người gỡ phải đi gửi
tôi chẳng hiểu Nó là điểm gì nhưng về
sau tôi chuẩn về sao Thôi mẹ ân hận là
bởi vì ạ gỡ cái này song nhiều cái phần
mềm không chạy được bởi nhiều phần mềm
để bắt buộc phải có cái này nó chạy được
Thế Chi móng cài một phần mềm mà đó là
đôi khi là nó sẽ cài thêm những cái hỗ
trợ cho cái ấy chạy và nó chính là C + +
hai cái gì đó acid servo kia là để mặt
ngôn ngữ để mà chạy cái phần mềm đấy
hoặc lại em quê server để lưu lại các dữ
liệu của phần mềm đấy thế nên là mấy ông
gỡ cái này ra mấy phần mềm viện không
chạy luôn đấy thì nữa Đừng đừng như tôi
nhé
khi
tôi dùng cái á stickynote Để mà kiểu nó
Nó kiểu nốt luôn kiểu hiển thị ra đây nó
rất là tiện nhưng mà tôi vẫn dùng luôn
cả thằng mai có súp doo doo
a thodu này bởi vì a tôi thấy nó đồng bộ
lên cả trên qua điện thoại của tôi nữa
Nếu dùng sai rõ là có những có một vài
phần mềm khác cũng tương tự nhưng mà nó
không có cả ở windows nó cả cả ở
cả trên điện thoại nên tôi thích dùng
thằng này
a viscose tôi lỡ cài tôi tôi sẽ xóa đi
Ừ cái này nghe mặc định của cài Win mấy
cái này có này
xe máy ép wespen này ra tôi thấy không
thích lắm à
Ừ cái này tự nhiên mày Ông thấy bình
thường cái cái cái này cho miễn phí
ở công ty nhé
ở đây tôi lướt qua xem còn gì không
ừ ừ
[âm nhạc]
ở Zalo cho bạn nào kiểu chưa biết thì
chơi lô này nó là cái á cũng là để mà
Ừ cái mặt để mở quản lý các công việc
của ông các thứ thứ ông ghi chủ lại tôi
là một người ghi dù rất là nhiều bởi vì
mình không nên mình không nên kiểu cậy
não mình nhớ tốt mình tôi bảo rồi những
cái gì mà máy tính làm được thì mình
không cần phải nhớ Nhưng hãy để máy tính
làm vụ đấy đúng ạ Hãy để não mình kiểu
thứ thư giãn một tí cậu không cần lấy
nhớ mời ông đôi khi thật nhớ đủ thứ
nếu phải nói phải ghi chú lại hết các
thứ thứ và ghi chú cách khoa học đối thủ
ghi chú rất nhiều Tôi thấy khả năng làm
việc của tôi nó cũng là rất chuyên
nghiệp đi tôi phải dùng từ chuyên nghiệp
bởi vì ạ tôi ghi chú lại rất nhiều cái
khi mà tôi nói chuyện với các đối tác
hay nói chuyện với sếp tôi Mở ghi chú
tôi lên rồi tôi nói nói cậu liền mạch
các cư xử rất ổn mà giống như ở bản báo
cáo có người chửi xong rồi Kiểu
ở những kẻ anh em đồng nghiệp khác của
tôi thì kiểu
chẳng ghi chú Cái gì kia không
biết báo cáo cái gì có thứ tự mang tiền
ông tôi không thể dân kế toán không phải
là thư ký nói tôi ghi chú rất là đủ các
thử mọi thứ dễ nghe tôi vẫn khẳng định
là tôi làm việc chuyên nghiệp
gì hả Tôi có chơi game mà chẳng có rồi
không Giới thiệu mày ông ấy không phải
tự biết
cho con đi nha
Ừ
chắc hết rồi
em nhớ hết rồi đại Khải có ông biết qua
được một vài cái thôi
a thào nhớ vẫn còn hồi trước tôi cài Hồi
trước tôi cả nhiều chẳng qua tôi bị Tôi
gỡ vợ đi cài lại máy nhiều nên là tôi bị
mất ấy rồi chứ tôi có nhiều cái hay lắm
anh đợi mình một tí lại
Ừ Đúng rồi hình như tôi gỡ đi nhiều nên
là lại ít cái mà chia sẻ trong bé uống
hết rồi hôm đấy tôi cài rất nhiều cái mà
tôi cảm thấy hay ho thôi cái nhưng mà
Chính vì nó hay ho nhưng mà chỉ dùng 12
lần nên là tôi mấy kiểu bây giờ tôi còn
không nhớ là tôi cài lại
Ừ nếu mà nói chung ở khi nào mà có gì
tôi sẽ chắc là đăng bài lên như tim công
ty để cho mấy ông mấy ông xem qua lại
bài hát em vẫn nhìn vào cái thư mục
Action sân này của tôi đúng không
Ừ cái
Ừ cái này
Em làm về cái tiện ích tôi lưu lại mà
Thì có cái tiện ích này Hồi đấy tôi làm
việc làm với
cậu em sinh năm 2k hay tôi từng nó giới
thiệu qua cái đứa em ấy rồi Kiểu quê tôi
một trong những đứa học trò đầu tiên tôi
dạy gia sư theo kiểu là vệ gia sư lập
trình ấy chỉ cần dậy nó một vài buổi bây
giờ nó thành một thằng đội trưởng ấy thì
à
Chúng tôi sẵn đứa em để chuyên gia Swift
với nó làm cái Tĩnh hàng cho tôi cái
tiện ích này là kiểu về tổng hợp rất
nhiều phím tắt bao gồm phím rất tải ảnh
ở được trên rất nhiều trang hay ạ bấm
phím tắt này nó sẽ mở cái gì đó lên về
sau tôi giới thiệu chứ không mấy cái thì
cũng tương tự để mày ông biết cách làm
tiện ích cũng như
cậu có chuyện Nếu Để ý kỹ trên thanh này
của bộ có rất nhiều cái thực âm nó là ra
Suite đấy Bấm vào nó sẽ mở được cái gì
Đợi gì đòi lấy Tôi Sẽ Về do tôi sẽ dạy
mày ông về mấy cái này à
à à
để tham khảo cách chế loa đây tôi thử mở
ông có cái Zalo của tôi nhé đây tôi vì
nốt lại tất cả những cái thứ mà tôi
Ừ tôi sẽ hỏi này tôi hỏi sếp sẽ có những
cái gì những cái gì tôi đang cầm làm đấy
đấy mở lên nó sẽ bị trước ít này cái này
nó có thể tích hợp thêm rất nhiều cái
kẹp power-up này nó thể tích hợp thêm
rất nhiều cái tiện ích nữa chắc là mình
phải mò mò dần em ấy ông mới hiểu
Ê mấy ông đang cứ hỏi tôi về chia sẻ cấu
hình máy tính thức A máy tính của tôi
tôi từng đăng bài Phút về cái máy này
rồi vợ ạ Tuy trong bố mẹ lúc đầu có phải
rất chị mày chặn các thứ nhưng mà ra là
nó không như thế nó đều ấy chưa ạ
cho
tôi từ 57 phút rồi lại những 40 phút rồi
Cái cái bên đấy rồi Nhưng tôi sẽ không
tăng nữa chứ
à à
mà bạn 2k hay đấy á bạn 2k hay lấy là
người sống nội tâm đến chắc là tôi không
thể chia sẻ cho mấy ông cái gì đâu tôi
chỉ bật mí một tí ở ông đấy cũng từng là
kiểm duyệt của nó từng từng làm kiểm
duyệt nhóm thôi
Ừ Ok chắc à phạm mới thế Hôm nay anh sẽ
ra mình chưa biết chia sẻ cái gì cả bài
tập thì tôi cũng sẽ đăng lên và ngắm
thôi đúng không ạ
em buổi sau mình sẽ học thời gian switch
Ừ chắc là từ buổi sau nó sẽ khó và khô
khan hơn về nhà không chuyên giao diện
nữa nó sẽ khô khan hơn một tí bắt đầu từ
buổi sau luôn buổi sau lại là nhảy sang
lập trình nó không làm về giao diện nữa
sẽ phải có tí động não nhiều hơn Đây là
mấy ông cũng chuẩn bị tâm lý rất là vừa
đúng không ạ Thôi chào các bạn nhé Ừ ok
ừ ừ